foreign
[Music]
Josh Wells president of film independent
welcome to film independent presents
very excited today to be talking with
the filmmakers of descendants and um
before we Dive Right In I want to thank
uh the hfpa and vision media for their
support of film independent presents
year round
um thank you so much and thanks also to
Netflix thanks for making today's event
possible with that it is really a huge
pleasure and honor entries the director
of descendant Margaret Brown
hey Josh and the producers of this
incredible film and Essie Chambers Kyle
and Essie thanks so much for being here
oh our pleasure thank you thanks for
having us yeah so I feel so fortunate to
just watch this film
um oh my God it is amazing uh it's so
beautiful and I honestly didn't know you
know I heard great things about it but I
had no idea what to expect and the
experience of watching it is really
extraordinary I mean Margaret all your
accounts but this one I feel is so I
mean it's gorgeous it's moving it's
infuriating it's um
uh well
I I
get into the questions as opposed to
describing my my emotional reaction to
watching it but um to start let me ask
I'm curious when you started work on
this and and when the idea of the
project came to you
um so in was it 20 I think it was 2018
they thought you guys remember 2018.
there was they thought they found the
ship
and um and there was always a flurry of
Articles
um and people started sending me emails
and text messages and messages on social
media saying have you seen these
articles because um order of myths a
film I made in 20
2005 it came out
um was it was about segregated Mardi
Gras in Mobile where I grew up and it
actually was focused around the clotilda
um Helen Mayer who's in this film her
family she was the queen of Mardi Gras
in 2000 oh no wait I got the year wrong
it was 2007. oh my God I was going back
another movie um it was 2007 and um and
so she was the white Mardi Gras queen
that year and Stephanie Lucas whose
family was descended from the club tilt
that was brought over on the clotilde
was the black Mardi Gras Queen and we
knew I knew um that it was sort of a
whisper campaign people would say like
oh that the mayor family like they
brought they brought the last slave ship
over but it was something that people
didn't really talk about it was like a
whisper kind of thing but then we were
filming with Stephanie Lucas and her
grandfather sort of just a matter of
fact he said that his family was
descended off the ship and then the film
became order of myths became kind of
centered around that and um
and so that was the reason everyone was
sending me all the Articles and saying
are you gonna make a follow-up are you
and I was just at the beginning I was
like no I you know um and then I was
having breakfast with one of the
producers of this film Lewis Black he
was an associate producer but the reason
you know he kind of got that credit was
because he
um was like Margaret we were having
breakfast in La and he was like are you
crazy like you've got to go go just like
see what's there see if there's a story
and he like literally handed me a check
and told me to get on a plane and I did
and
um you know one thing I realized and
people have been saying this we've been
emailing me was it wasn't it wasn't
about the ship it was about the
community so in a way it never even
mattered to me if they did find the ship
because I knew there was a story in the
community regardless
so this so awareness like you grew up in
Mobile so this was something you knew
about from when you were a kid no
really it wasn't no no I didn't I didn't
no I didn't learn about it in school
people didn't talk about it
um it was kind of like I mean I'm sure
like the mayor family knew about it but
it wasn't it was like again my mother I
think it was my mother that told me you
know when I said I was gonna start
making this movie The Order Of myths she
sort of said to me well you know that
family is supposed to have brought it
was like she said it like almost like it
was a rumor or something I mean I really
do think it took finding the ship for
like white people to be like oh there's
a ship
wow amazing
um so wait so that was in 2018 but when
did you when did you start working on
the film in 2018 okay and when was the
bulk of production happening how long
were you shooting we were shooting up
until November of
um this year
okay 20 21 20 21 oh sorry 2021.
um and can you so you I know you grew up
in Mobile but can you talk about your
sort of the experience of filming in the
community in Africa town and sort of
what was what was production like I'm
assuming you had a small uh crew but
what was what was that process
yeah I mean I we we sort of it's sort of
like a bit of a traveling circus like I
I kind of work with the same people over
and over
um and yeah we we kind of um uh I guess
like there was a lot of press kind of
coming in and out but like
um we we pretty much camped out there I
mean it was cool because like I could
stay with my parents and shoot and um a
lot of our crew is from New Orleans so
it was easy for them to get over there
um so I mean Kyle and SC were in New
York but um I mean maybe they could talk
about the shoots more than me
Carl do you want to take that one
uh Kyle it's also if you could just talk
I'm curious Kyle and Essie how you when
you guys got involved in the project and
um
sort of your role throughout
yeah you want to go ahead Essie
um I actually came to the project a
little bit later uh Mark I'm also a
writer in addition to being a producer
and Margaret and I were in an artist
residency together and so
um you know we became friends and and we
were we've been talking about we've been
I've been talking to her about the
project and kind of like sort of
unofficially advising her
um and and at a certain point she said
you have to meet Kyle you have to we'd
love for you to come on board as a
producer
um and you know the timing was great
this was this was actually before
Margaret said that you know there was a
there was a false finding of the ship
um and I came on board before the actual
finding of the ship and also
um only thought that the search for the
ship would ever be a frame that wasn't
that wasn't our focus it was the thing
to wrap the story around and so it was
an incredible moment of time when you
know our Consciousness was shifting
there was the 1619 project and all of
these other bigger conversations that we
were joining that were about out how we
think about black history inside of you
know American history and how how we
could recenter that thinking and so it
was just it was like the sort of the
perfect moment to join
the the the team and the telling of the
story
so yeah I think that was the so maybe
the spring of 2019
so I know the the
um person book uh Barbara Coon came out
in 2018 as well and I'm wondering was
that something did that it
I'm sure you were obviously aware of
that when the book came out but was that
when did that become part of the film
sort of the way that's woven into it
that was it I mean I wanted to do that
from the beginning
um
um we missed Kyle's answer but um
um but uh it
yeah I mean I I I read barracun but then
I also read the letters of zorniel
Hurston and the letters really
made her come alive for me I mean I love
bear coon and I knew I wanted that text
to sort of be a huge part of the film
but her there was something in her
letters about like I sort of she became
really alive for me as a person and I
got really obsessed with her so
um and and it sort of helped me figure
out like how to use barricone in a way
like reading because her her voice was
so strong in the letters
one of the things I love about the film
is you have there's archival material in
the film there's film and photos but
they are never just presented as in a
traditional you know
way it's it's generally you see
people who live in the community today
interacting with those texts and images
you see people reading from barricoon or
looking at the images and it makes it I
I it creates a sense of time in the film
I think is really extraordinary
um and I have to say I did not know that
this is sharing my ignorance I didn't
know that zory nail person was a
filmmaker and the footage I don't think
many people do of Cujo just is like an
119 moment in the film I know
when that clip plays I just again like
my reaction that moment is like I could
not believe that he lived in a moment
when there was a moving picture and to
see him acting in the lens it's just
like oh my God like the second time is
suddenly compressed in a really powerful
way I mean yeah it's sort of like when
those shiver things you're like well I
mean the way you think about history is
that being a long time ago is not a long
time ago yeah exactly
and also just the parallels of of you
know barracun couldn't be
um you know
published until 2018 because you know
they she wanted to publish it in dialect
and and at the time that that's not what
they wanted so the idea it was kind of
another layer of a denial of a history
and so
um you know there there's that in common
there's there's Zora Neil and then
there's Dr Kern Jackson who is kind of
like our modern day Zora and and the
line that we're drawing between the two
of them and so it was just yeah I mean
Margaret from the very beginning this
was going to be the poetic kind of glue
for the for the story
I I also thought I mean this is on the
same same theme that you create this
sense of time by right in a lot of ways
the filming it's very simple like you're
in the you're in the Contemporary World
filming real people just going about
their lives walking down the street
being in a cemetery and talking but just
through those images you create a sense
of time and history that is so
uh
powerful right I mean it's like the
sense of history of that community and
space and people grappling with what
happened to it people not knowing and
talking about you know what they know
what they believe what they think it
just brings I I can't think of another
film that does that in that way I think
I mean I don't know what Kyler Essie
would say this but I mean I feel like
it's because it's there it's not because
I'm putting it there it's because it's
literally there like they're on historic
ground like everything they're doing is
suffused with the past and you know I so
I don't think I I mean I I'm glad you
feel that way and I take the compliment
but I also think it's because of what it
is that it seems that way there's a lot
of just Serendipity I think with this
project I mean it touches on the
barracun thing where I think you know
the the biggest partner of this movie is
the community in Africa and all those
people and we couldn't this this we
couldn't make this movie the movie is
not you know this this is their story
and it couldn't be told without them
without their participation and I think
just a Confluence of barracun and the
finding of the ship it was like it was
like wait a minute there is this history
here and is it a coincidence that bear
Coon is coming out now it's like maybe
now is our time to like step forward and
tell our story and I think there was
like a real lightning rod where everyone
just sort of coalesced around this
moment
um and and we were sort of lucky enough
uh to kind of be a participant in it
um but it really adds this whole sort of
um just qualitative experience that glue
that I think you're talking about with
place and time it really kind of ties it
all together
one of the most Vivid parts of the film
for me was the the focus on community
activism right that these people in the
community are active and they're they're
coming together they're having meetings
they're figuring out what they're going
to do they're saying oh we're going to
write a constitution or you know let's
look at you know how that company got to
own the land let's like do a deep dive
on that it's really
um those scenes are just like wonderful
and like full of energy and again it's
like it's a it's driven by that sense of
history that the place has but it's was
that something that surprised you or it
was unexpected when you got into the
film or
um I don't know if either of you want to
take that but I have something to say
about that
go for it okay well I mean when I
started
um I I was very taken by like we'd go to
all these meetings to kind of start the
film and just take the Pulse of what was
going on and it was kind of incredible
that there were all these activist
groups I was just like what like this is
not a huge Community but there's like a
meeting about everything about the
environment about about the um there's
going to be like I don't know if what
you guys saw today there this is on the
cut that you saw but there's there's
going to be a website at the end and and
you know there's so there's so many
you'll get a chance to like see all the
groups that are are are active in Africa
town it's like and and we couldn't even
fit them all in it's like astonishing
you know um the level of activism in the
community to protect the community
um you know protect the land to protect
um the environment like the the school
there has a very active
um Alumni Association and and I think
like we were like oh my God like I mean
I grew up in Mobile and like I you know
know I did go to some activist stuff
growing up but like there's like people
in their 80s going to a meeting twice a
day I was incredible and it also I mean
it's just activism is part of their
history because especially within the
churches it goes all the way back to the
the original Church in in Africa town so
it's it's it's just it's it's tradition
it's a part of their history
um yeah
so I mean how many there are we follow
four or five in the film but yeah
there's Margaret's point they're so
they're they're more than that
um there are a number of scenes that
really
um popped out at me but a couple I
wanted to mention there's one I think
it's at the scene it's a community
Gathering maybe it's where they're
they're sort of
um the ship has been found and there's
there's like sort of a celebration
around but you talk to this woman
somewhat older woman and her daughter
and it's the older woman who says it's
it's like this cycle and we've returned
to the beginning and then the she walks
away and it's just a incredible moment
where the daughter takes this sigh
because it's like she clearly has a
different take on it or she she sees her
mother's view but then she says this
beautiful thing says I don't want to be
a part of it I want to be a which I
thought was like that and you let that
moment play out and it was just like
incredible like you see the the full
impact of this moment for yeah people
who live there no I mean when she said
it I knew it would be in the movie
because I felt it in that moment like
you know I mean via's like vida's like
um she's an amazing woman and you know
you see her developed through the film
um and I don't know I yeah she's she I
feel like the way she sees things really
mirrors like how I saw things you know
and so
um yeah I was I always I always wanted
to ask Vito whenever she was at
something I would always get her to
you know and also um one thing I don't
want to hog the conversation too much
but like a lot of the filmmaking was you
know me having coffee with people like
when we weren't even filming and talking
about things and
um it wasn't all in front of the camera
it was
um it was like you know
a lot of times in in films I've this was
like a real like I really really wanted
to know like how they felt about
everything and how they're being
portrayed and and what they thought was
important and um I just
yeah I would say like so much time was
just spent coffees and drinks and meals
and for years
and that stuff I think is what it really
like that kind of off-screen work is the
kind of thing that develops trust with
vita so that when she's in front of the
camera she feels comfortable just saying
what she thinks and not sugar coating it
or not doing a song and dance because
the camera's rolling and we just got
it's just like really really lucky uh to
find people that were like willing to be
just candid with us about that and just
sort of genuine vulnerable yeah yeah
I I found myself wondering about that uh
as I was watching because there are
there are scenes like that where it's
one person but you also have these group
scenes like in you know they're in like
a big conference room and the camera
you're really like up moving around
catching Snippets of conversation where
people still feel very unguarded and
talking to each other about you know
their
their ancestors and uh um
in in just being very seemingly very
relaxed on camera
um oh no to Kyle have to go to the
meeting yeah he did okay well I mean I
can speak to that like I
um
Kyle is taking care of a last minute
problem we're still fixing things
um so uh yeah like I mean I do think we
were always kind of there filming so I
do think that people were very used to
our cameras being part of
um being part of the wallpaper you know
and also like in some of these meetings
there's a ton of press there so like
there's cameras everywhere so I think
that those two factors
yeah I mean it's one of the first things
that I noticed when I joined is that um
you know there were these hot they're
The Hot Flashes where the Behold The
Press would come in you know when the
ship was almost about you know all these
different moments and what people said
is you know people come in and out but
Margaret keeps coming and I think that
was reflected in those Mo in in the kind
of community meetings where
where you know we did become flies on
the wall because we kept coming
and and stayed
yeah and like they they know they know
our crew like like they you know we're
all talking we're all having meals
together when we're not shooting you
know not always but like it was very
everyone knew everyone
I wanted to ask also excuse me about
there's a great scene it's a scene on
the boat when they go out to where the
wreck was found and and
I'm sorry I'm terrible with names I
don't remember the people's names but
you it's the scene where
older white guys talking about his
ancestor who was like had a good
character and then the other man says
well good Master bad Master
you know not not good either way and
that scene was like again it was like
it's not like a conflictual or
confrontational scene but there's
clearly
conflict there and like
but the way
everybody's speaking very openly on
camera as you're there
I'm just curious what that what that was
like in terms of capturing that moment
I mean we were both there
um I mean again like when you see a
moment like that it's like to me I mean
Essie definitely should speak to this
too but I mean it's I think it's a
moment that
um I've seen so many moments like that
in my life you know where some uh
someone says something and it's like try
a white person's saying something that
they think somehow I don't know how
really but like um that that's okay to
say and um you know and of course the
camera sees it very differently
um and it's like a really painful moment
you know and um and he gets corrected
but does it even really land and I think
I just knew I had to keep it in the film
because it's such like one of those
moments it's a real like for a lack of a
it's overused phrase but it's a
teachable moment you know it's like
right you know you see that and you're
like oh my God
yeah I mean the other context to add is
we were right near the Rec site I mean
we are if not above it and so right
there yeah it was it was um everyone was
so raw emotionally and so
um I always I hate saying this because I
you know when a black person responds
with grace to something that is
offensive it's sort of like ugh I I hate
to put that burden to come out as the
gentleman who said you know good Master
bad Master still master in my mind what
um but but it's true I mean he handled
that with Grace
um and I think I I think it was a it was
about a lot of different things
um a little big part of it having to do
with the fact that we the proximity that
we had to this horror and the way that
the buttons that was pushing in all of
us
yeah another scene that struck me it's
it's has a sort of a different emotional
color than that one but the scene in the
cemetery when there's the kind of the
the white guy who's like Professor who
says oh yeah I write barracuna it was
like really sad and the Young Guy's like
he's like yeah it used to make me cry
but you know we're here it doesn't make
me sad anymore that was such a powerful
scene I loved it I mean that guy the the
descendant of Cujo
he is yeah I mean he's
he's so in command of
um his emotional range like he so knows
himself it's incredible
um he has so much maturity and I think
you know he was 27 when we shot that or
something
when you were near he feels like royalty
or something he's just either there is a
real magical quality about him like he
is just literally channeling ancestors I
mean it's pretty it's pretty incredible
he's a leader like through and through
and that guy again it was like it's like
oh even he goes oh cool cool I was like
really right
it
um I wanted to ask you about there's a
scene
um
it's in the the kind of the big fancy
Historical house and
um it's a long shot where
the person speaking is describing how
the house makes him feel and that like
bad shit went down here but the entire
shot is is of water and it's his voice
over the water and I just want to talk I
hear you talk about how how you came
over that it's a really powerful moment
in the film
well actually that idea is um my editor
Mike's idea
um and I had to really fight for that
idea once he did it I was like yes
that's perfect
um but everyone was like can't we see
something and I was like no like you
should listen to what he's saying and
it's okay if it's a long moment
um and and um you know but yeah that's
the kind of things that
um
that everyone but the film team kind of
wants to cut usually
um but I think it really allows you to
listen to what he's saying and how how
it struck him and
um and that was to me that was once I
saw it I was like yeah that's what it
has to be
but it wasn't my idea yeah
yeah wow amazing well I'm glad it's in
the film it's an incredible and
not that this is why it's powerful it's
like a gorgeous shot for one thing just
of the water and yeah it forces you to
listen but then I found myself thinking
about oh what's under the water Yeah
well yeah exactly yeah it's like it's
like um you know I I don't I I think
like often people like are afraid to let
the audience think you know and sit with
sit with the feeling and I wanted people
to sit with feelings and think you know
and and and have mine wander in certain
directions like I wasn't afraid of that
like I think the audience is smarter
than often times we give them
or I'm not going to say I mean I always
want to respect my audience to to like
let their mind go where it goes
yeah
um well the the last thing I wanted to
ask is just about there's like a it's a
major part of the film that we haven't
talked about yet but is all of the
environmental stuff like the present day
issues like people talking about again
it's the community activism part of it
but all the people who have family
members die of cancer or people in the
films prostate I it's like the impact of
the legacy of that history how it's
manifest now in the companies that
control the space and pollute the space
and are causing physical harm to the
descendants of the clotilda it's it's
um
again when you started the film were you
expecting that to end up being part of
the story or was that something you
found as you spent time there well I
mean I growing up in Mobile you know
about that like you know about like
where the industrial stuff is like I
mean I definitely knew where Africa town
was situated
um that's not a secret
um I didn't know like the sort of the
details and I think a lot of that is
still unfolding like there's there
hasn't been a whole lot of money spent
for environmental Remediation in Africa
Town that's a problem so I mean a lot of
that has to still be uncovered like the
the work is being done now that's
something that people can help with
um so yeah I mean Ramsay and Joe like
their their lives are dedicated to that
work and um you know we just hope when
people see this film they'll want to
join join them
yeah right Margaret always says the
great thing it's sort of like there was
a moment when she when she first visited
Africa town and she smelled the
chemicals
um and and and understood where this
poison was meeting people and wanting to
figure out how do I capture this in film
and I think you know
turning points for social justice
movements are often just turning a
camera on an injustice and so the hope
is that yeah this film like you know
when you see it and you you just you
can't believe
at this well you can believe this is
America it's happening in a lot of black
communities but um but it's hard not to
want to do something when you see it
yeah
to that point could you talk a little
bit about the release of the film and so
you're doing this it's participant in
higher ground and I'm curious sort of
you know compared to order of myths or
your other forms is there a different
approach to releasing the film in your
hopes oh yeah
well an order of Miss came out it was it
was a recession it was 2008 and like I
hardly you know got any support for the
I mean Cinema Guild Cinema Guild did the
best they could but it was Tiny
distributor and um and I mean Netflix so
many people are going to get to see this
film and and
um I'm so excited about it um you know
participant in Higher Ground are
incredible partners and obviously the
Obamas like the they they came and spoke
before the film at um the film festival
in Martha's Vineyard and they were so it
was incredible to have you know I mean I
think of myself as like fairly
articulate but when they introduce your
film you're like oh I'm not articulate I
can barely speak the ABCs like the way
they spoke about it I was just like oh
my God like this is you know a dream
like they're gonna Inspire so many
people to care about these issues that
might maybe might not
um and then
um with participant one reason I like to
work with participant is they have a
very robust impact side so when the film
ends and you're having your postpartum
about like what am I going to do I care
about this thing and it's done the
impact team comes on and a whole team of
people who who like work with the
community to like further the goals of
the movie and we I mean Essie and I've
been witnessing their work and it is
like sometimes I'm just like crying on
the zoom you know it's it's really what
they're doing for the community and it's
setting up something over a multi-year
period
um they're you know they're they're the
way they're amplifying what's already
happening
um is really incredible and um and I so
I feel like the work is just starting
you know with the environmental work
that what they're helping like sort of
um the Coalition building I mean again
with things that are already in place
but um but you know giving it to a wider
audience
amazing wow that's great well
um Margaret and Essie thank you so much
for for taking time to talk with with
film independent today congrats on the
film it's so beautiful uh everyone
watching this q a has well initially
we'll have seen the film but if you
haven't seen the film yet please please
watch it when it's when it's live and um
thank you again both so much thank you
Josh thank you so much for having us
yeah of course thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign